unless you have no eyebrows at all or
it's like a unibrow that's the only time
my nose eyebrows we're straight guys
here to review hot guys's eyebrows
Slater yes
he's got great eyebrows decorate
everything man this man puts more effort
into his eyebrows then I put any into
anything in my life
you got that Latin Flair you know that
fullness to him and I got to give it to
him hot eyebrows eyebrows on fleek I
think this is a very handsome gentleman
but his eyebrows don't do it for me I
would say this guy needs more eyebrow
yeah me too
I would like to see this guy with more
eyebrow let's just call a spade a spade
these are bad I'm yeah it has nothing to
do with the thickness it's like it's
like the shape it goes yeah yeah hmm
yeah dang this guy's just a hottie man
he's so hot and he's got an accent Oh
butchy these are pushy you know I'd say
these are actually pretty sexy these are
sexy brows now this is a guy where like
the first thing you notice fibers yeah
unlike those due to his eyebrows don't
have great density but amazing color
this guy I think like perfect they're
strong they're pretty even yeah I mean
that's those are attractive eyebrows and
I want to be friends with them hey the
greatest eyebrows in the game dude it's
like two 45s strapped to the front of
his face if you're in a bar fight there
the eyebrows you want your side
world-class I'm probably the best
eyebrows on anyone he's legendary for
this thing right he tried to patent or
he tried to trademark the unibrow it's
so symmetrical I'm tempted to say on
it's almost like he has a third eyebrow
between his brow I saw him in an
interview of him saying I'm never
shaving the brow he likes it he's like
this is my trademark and it's smart his
nickname is the brow that's almost like
a woman with three breasts it's it's
it's hot in concept but if you were to
add
you see it I think you'd be horrible I
can't I I should say it's not hot but
I'm I am attracted to it he played the
vampire in the movies right not the
werewolf but he looks like he played the
werewolf here everything's kind of like
it looks like he just changed back from
being a werewolf I would fall in love
eternally with these eyebrows toy
records this guy what if I would have
lost out on a lot of roles if it weren't
for those eyebrows really yes mijo that
was horrifying I just put my finger over
the eyebrows Robert Pattinson beautiful
I burn these pensions nothing without
his brows you heard it here first
nothing nothing those eyebrows are MVP